ما انحطت الطائره التي تقل الوفد
الفلسطيني القادم من قمه العقبه في رام
الله حتى اشتعلت الارض في نابلس
المستوطنون بالمئات يهاجمون القرى
والبلدات الفلسطينيه قتلوا شابا فلسطينيا
واصابوا العشرات بجروح احرقوا عشرات
المنازل والسيارات
[موسيقى]
باقي القلم كمان ذابحين القلم
هجوم المستوطنين غذته تصريحات لوزراء في
حكومه نتنياهو وزير الماليه والمسؤول عن
اداره شؤون الاحتلال في الضفه
علق بالاعجاب على تغريده لرئيس مجلس
المستوطنات في الشمال والذي يطالب بحرق
مزيد من القرى الفلسطينيه اما بنجافير
فقال انما حدث في قمه العقبه سيبقى في
العقبه وتوجه لدعم مجموعه من المستوطنين
اعادوا بناء بؤره استيطانيه جنوبي نابلس
فيما طالب نتنياهو المستوطنين بعدم اخذ
الثار من عمليه حواره التي ادت لمقتل
اثنين من المستوطنين بايديهم وان الجيش
النظامي هو من سيفعل ذلك
سالك اخوته بيتخون الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوات
الامن تقوم حاليا بملاحقه القاتل سوف نعثر
عليه ونقبض عليه ونصفي الحساب معه اطلب
منكم حتى عندما يكون الدم فائرا والغضب
كبيرا الا تاخذ القانون بايديكم اتركوا
الجيش وقوى الامن تقوم بعملها
[تصفيق]
السلطه الفلسطينيه في موقف محرج للغايه
فهي التي توجهت لقمه العقبه للاجتماع مع
وفد اسرائيلي لبحث سبل التهدئه رغم
الانتقادات الشعبيه والسياسيه المحليه
وجدت نفسها تطلق قنابل الغاز على مجموعه
من المتظاهرين في نابلس حاولوا احراق مكان
يعتبره اليهود مقدسا كما انها تعجز عن
توفير الحمايه لمواطنيها الذين يتعرضون
لاعتداءات المستوطنين نتائج قمه العقبه
السياسيه والامنيه تصطدم بواقع معقد
اسرائيل منقسمه بين مجتمع مدني في تل ابيب
يتظاهروا لاصلاحات قضائيه ودوله مستوطنين
في الضفه الغربيه يقودها وزراء متطرفون
اما الفلسطينيون فينقسمون بين سلطه تحاول
تغليب الحكمه السياسيه والتماشي مع
الاراده الامريكيه وشارع يخوض مواجهه
يوميه مع المستوطنين والجيش الاسرائيلي
قادمه عبد الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه